hey this is Sarah with registered nurse
Orion comm and today I want to talk to
you about how to put on sterile gloves
as a nurse you will be required to use
sterile gloves when you insert Foley
catheters when you access sub-q ports or
when you change central line dressings
now whenever I was a nursing student I
actually had was tested on how to put on
these gloves so if you're a nursing
student you may be tested by your
clinical instructor on how to put them
on and you can use this video as a quick
reference on how to put them on so first
what we're going to do is you'll get
your sterile gloves sterile gloves come
in different sizes so be sure to pick
the correct size of sterile gloves if
you're a man you'll probably need larger
gloves they come in small medium or
large or they're labeled with a number
and these are size six they're on the
smaller side because I have small hands
so I'm going to use these so first what
you'll do is you'll open up your sterile
gloves and before you put on your gloves
of course you'll want to do hand hygiene
either wash your hands with soap and
water or use the alcohol sanitizer now
when if you're inserting a Foley
catheter or you're going to change a
central line dressing it'll come in a
package like this okay it won't have
this whip it'll come right back so what
you'll do is you unfold it and when you
unfold it you will see these little
creases around here this is for you to
open them without contaminating the
gloves so what I like to do is I like to
take my fingers and I like to reach
underneath and grab these little flaps
right here so I can pull them open and
remember you have two inches to grab so
you won't contaminate the field and I'm
pulling them open and see how it's
wanting to close like that that's okay
that's normal it happens so just pull it
out you have the two inches remember and
flatten it out and you have your gloves
you have your left glove and your right
glove first thing you want to do is
you'll want to glove your dominant hand
I'm right-handed
so I'm going to go up my right hand
first and if you're left-handed
you'll glove your left hand first so
what I'll do is I'll get my left hand
ready to glove my right hand okay what
I'll do is I'll take my fingers and I'm
going to grasp this cuff right here
they'll be folded like that in the
little plastic thing and grab them like
that and what I want to do is I'm going
to keep my thumb tucked in because this
will allow me to slide the glove on a
lot easier without my thumb getting in
the way and if your thumb gets in the
way you may touch the outside of the
glove and contaminate it so keep it
tucked in just going to grab and you're
just going to take your hand down in the
glove just pull it up and I'm pulling
with this it's okay to do that and I've
pulled it up my arm and I'm sterile
hands or sterile and take your fingers
with the little comb and just pull it up
your arm make them fit a little bit
better okay this hand is sterile do not
touch anything other than this glove and
the inside of the surface because you
will contaminate your gloves don't touch
the bedside table your face your skin or
anything so now we're going to glove our
left hand we're going to take our right
hand and we're going to go underneath
this cup instead of grasping like we did
before we're going to go underneath it
okay and whenever you do that the paper
tends to move so just take your time
just sort of work your fingers
underneath there and you're going to
hold it okay because we have went
underneath here and we're not grasping
like we did before and to help us to put
it on better we're going to keep our
thumb out remember how before I told you
to tuck it in we're going to keep it out
first and we're going to keep our
fingers together and we're going to
slide the glove up through those fingers
okay like this and you're pushing with
the other hand
now we're going to tuck the thumb under
so we can slide the glove just pull okay
and so on and sometimes the gloves will
be a little twisted or messed up you can
just take your hands and you can just
fix them and make them more comfortable
for you okay and we have our sterile
gloves on
okay usually what happens whatever you
are all sterile you have your gloves on
your face will itch or the patient will
need something so do not touch your face
don't touch the bedside table don't
touch the bed
don't touch anything because if you do
you'll have to repeat this whole
procedure over again and put your
sterile gloves on so I hope this video
helped you out if you like this video
please subscribe to my youtube channel
and share this video with your friends
also visit my website registered nurse
Orion comm for more information on
nursing school and how to succeed as a
nurse thank you so much for watching